I've been sort of predicting warning you guys,
everybody I've been talking to that the next
two years are going to be particularly insane
for two reasons, really three reasons.
One, a large part of the country and even
many of our elected officials wrongly believe
that the president, Joe Biden, will be illegitimate,
that the election was really won by Donald
Trump and Joe Biden stole it.
That radicalizes people.
No to right wing media is going to be crazier
than ever.
Fox News now not radical enough, but fear
not.
Newsmax and on and some other online platforms
and outlets are amping up the crazy and they
will be going absolutely no holds barred nuts
during the next two years.
And number three, we actually have Kuhnen
type conspiracy theorists who have been elected
to the House of Representatives.
We have absolutely nutty Republicans that
if you this is not praise of like a Mitt Romney
Republican.
But if you put a Mitt Romney Republican next
to some of these people, it's hard to imagine
how they're even part of the same party at
all.
And I have a perfect example for you that
blends Kuhnen craziness with radical right
wing media.
And it is a story about the new brand new
kuhnen, Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor Green,
who has announced an impeachment of Joe Biden.
Now, you might be saying, wait a second, Joe
Biden is not even president yet.
What, impeaching Joe Biden?
What are you talking about?
Yes, and kooky Congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
Green announced it on Newsmax.
Where else?
It's too crazy for Fox News.
So she went on Newsmax and she starts stammering
because even she doesn't fully seem to understand
why she's going to try to impeach Joe Biden.
Take a look.
Well, and yes, 10 or so Republicans did this
as well.
We'll have more on that in a bit.
Congresswoman, I understand, though, you have
something pressing, something important and
something new you'd like to share with everybody.
Yes, I would like to announce on behalf of
the American people, we have to make sure
that our leaders are held accountable.
We cannot have a president of the United States
that is willing to abuse the power of the
office of the presidency and be easily bought
off by foreign governments, foreign Chinese
or Chinese energy companies, Ukrainian energy
companies.
So on January 21st, I will be filing articles
of impeachment on Joe Biden.
Wow, articles of impeachment on Joe Biden
on his first full day as president, as funny
as her idiotic explanation is the Newsmax
host Greg Kelley's reaction when she sort
of like pretending this is huge breaking news.
But in reality, she's she's just a lunatic,
radical right winger speaking nonsense.
Him having to pretend like this is.
Wow, very, very powerful is part of what makes
that clip just unbelievable.
Now, she may well be telling the truth that
she's going to draft impeachment articles
against Joseph R. Biden Jr. on January 21st.
Twenty, twenty one, just seven days from today.
What's nuts is we've been talking about are
Republicans going to impeach Joe Biden just
for the hell of it?
And apparently at least this one Republican
is going to it will go nowhere because Democrats
control the House and Democrats control the
Senate, and most importantly, because Joe
Biden hasn't done anything worthy of impeachment.
Of course.
And if you needed and this is an early signal
that, yes, these people are going to be just
as crazy as they were during their pre elected
official lives.
And, yes, right wing media is going to be
levels of crazy that we only previously sort
of skated by with FOX News.
Take the craziest thing that's ever happened
on Fox News.
That's going to be 24/7 on Newsmax and that's
going to be 24/7 on on.
So there's going to be no shortage of insanity
to debunk over the next two years and just
a few other.
We're going to talk about the metal detectors
at the House of Representatives on the bonus
show today.
So I don't want to say too much about it,
but we now have a House of Representatives
increasingly riddled with outrageous conspiracy
theorists and radicals.
Marjorie Taylor Greene, the woman in the video
we just played, a guy named Madison Cawthorn,
they've admitted that they carry firearms.
He admitted that he carries firearms with
him onto the House floor, multiple firearms.
He's in a wheelchair.
And he says the wheelchair allows him to actually
have multiple firearms with him.
Marjorie Taylor Greene saying she legally
has guns, so why shouldn't she be able to
have them on the floor of the House of Representatives
and now metal detectors are going in to try
to stop that.
So these are really scary, outrageous people
who are now in the House of Representatives.
And there's two ways that this could go.
The the optimistic path is that the election
of people like Marjorie Taylor Green and Madison
Cawthorn and others is a blip that, remember,
members of the House are up for reelection
every two years.
They're constantly their campaigns for reelection
are going to start in seven or eight months
already.
The hope would be they did in their particular
districts, very Trumpy districts ride the
wave of Trump ism to the House of Representatives
and that they'll be gone in two years.
That's the optimistic side, the more pessimistic
side.
And the scarier side is that although Donald
Trump will be gone, we talked about how his
impact will continue through the judges and
Supreme Court justices that he's selected.
This may also be the legacy of Trump.
People like these folks who may remain in
the House and there may be this wacky kuhnen
Trump in contingent that remains in the house
for some time.
It's very scary.
And we almost immediately I mean, listen,
they'll start campaigning in seven months,
will start dealing with it in seven, eight
months as well.
But we're going to have to activate to make
sure that these people are just one term members
of Congress.
And we'll have plenty of time to talk about
that